los talibanes ya tienen una primera
capital provincial en su dominio se
trata de la ciudad de sarán de la
provincia sureña de nimbus en afganistán
marcas de libros en ruso está bajo el
control de los talibanes la oficina del
gobernador el jefe del complejo policial
y todos los distritos de la ciudad han
sido capturados por los talibanes
esta es una victoria simbólica y un acto
desafiante de los insurgentes que tras
el retiro de las tropas internacionales
este año avanzan a pasos de gigante con
un solo objetivo en la mira el dominio
total del país la encarnizada lucha
contra las tropas del gobierno ha matado
a más de 1000 civiles en los últimos
meses miles más han sido desplazados o
están atrapados en ciudades sin poder
abandonar sus casas la onu advierte de
una carnicería
en las últimas semanas la guerra en
afganistán ha entrado en una nueva fase
más mortífera y destructiva la amenaza
de grandes áreas urbanas parece ser una
decisión estratégica de los talibanes
que han aceptado la probable carnicería
que se producirá
el avance de los talibanes suscita
nerviosismo a nivel internacional como
reflejo de la atención rusia ha
desplegado tropas en uzbekistán países
vecinos de afganistán ambos países junto
a tayikistán han desplegado ejercicios
militares en la frontera en medio del
temor de que la situación de inseguridad
en el país se expanda al resto de la
región